I understand you were just in New York
City how was it New York how did it go
he's great it was uh it was a lot of fun
I was staying on the east side which I
love and then what to see a friend
friend one day on the west side he said
come on come on over and I didn't
realize it was gay pride days it was it
was it was like a hundred and fifty
thousand men all very excited I have to
be wearing tank top cause it's hot out
during a tank top I was yeah ten people
short short and I'm virgin you were
wearing a big mustache just because it
was hot
you know and then I got chased down the
street by the alarms I chased down the
street by a large man wearing a sock
around his so we shouting Captain Kirk
[Applause]
quite a welcome to the city I think I
made it back of the hotel in 12 minutes
yeah that's so fascinating first of all
that the guys out just wearing a socks
yeah sees you and then it just has the
confidence to just go running after you
that was just like whoa and by
connivance you mean confidence in the
sock